it is a sight to behold but one which
future generations may not get to savor
this is an exhibition at London Zoo of
healthy coral originating from the
Chagos islands in the Indian Ocean but a
new study has revealed the devastating
impact warmer seas are having on the
rock like substances found on the seabed
the che cose Islands are a remote
archipelago in the Indian Ocean about
300 miles south of the Maldives
back-to-back heat waves killed 70
percent of che cose islands coral in two
years
although coral that survived the first
heat wave proved more resilient to the
second hotter heat wave when water is
too warm it can result in coral
bleaching which means they lose their
pigment and can turn white protected
area which means that there's no direct
human impacts there there's no fishing
there's very little pollution Branston
which means that we can really separate
the effects of climate change effects
from those of direct Shuman impacts so
some real evidence of the effects of
climate change on coral reefs which is
one of the most sensitive ecosystem
climate change is causing sea levels and
water temperatures to rise this new
research may help us better understand
how coral can weather and even
regenerate in a hotter world what it's
showing us this research is that nature
can adapt but if we push it too far then
it gets to the point where nature can't
bounce back and that's the point where
we're doing damage beyond repair and one
in six species for example is at risk of
extinction as a result of climate change
and it's that that that's the reason why
we need to act so urgently to try and
prevent this in the first place
by 2050 coral reefs are expected to have
diminished to such an extent they won't
be able to support marine life in the
way they currently do another
frightening insight into the devastation
being reaped by climate change Lisa
Holland Sky News